it's kind of a weird thing that's
happened with American society this idea
that you have to have a college degree
to be a respectable member of the middle
class because as recently 30 or 40 years
ago that wasn't really true hi I'm
Alexis Garcia with Reason TV and you
know him as its dependent he's the
author of the new book the new school
how the information age will save
American education from itself here with
me now is Glenn Reynolds so Glenn should
we be sending our kids to colleges right
now
I mean maybe but it shouldn't be the
thought-free default option if you send
kids to college there should be an
actual reason for it and the fact that
everybody else is doing isn't a good
enough reason right a lot from the
students perspective but I'm wondering
you know is there any functions that a
university does serve like scholarship
like your scholarship that could you
know potentially change kind of the
framework there you could possibly say
that it is worth it to go well well from
the standpoint of the university there
are loads of reasons to exist not least
of which is if you've seen that scene
from Blazing Saddles where governor or
lahpet Amane has all these cronies
around the table and he says gentlemen
we've got to protect our phony-baloney
jobs but from the student standpoint
given how expensive it is to go to
college there has to be a return
sufficient to make it worth the time and
especially the money when you could work
your way through college by waiting
tables going to college just to sort of
find yourself maybe made sense now that
even most state schools in state work
out to about a six-figure proposition by
the time you get your degree if you get
your degree you really have to think
about return on investment and I think
people have just started to do that more
seriously and that's actually beginning
to have impact on colleges already
you've been preaching for years now that
you know taking on this debt isn't worth
it do you think that students are
finally starting to listen oh yeah it's
really changed I mean the psychology of
student loan debt even just over the
last five years has changed dramatically
and the reason is people heard enough
horror stories that it's starting to
sink in and you know they used to do
this research back in the 80s and
they're trying to figure out what would
get people to practice safe sex what
they found was as soon as somebody knew
somebody
who had AIDS and it didn't have to be
somebody they knew well it could be you
know the friend of a brother or
something like that their behavior
changed almost overnight and I think the
same kind of thing is happening the
student loan debt that was just sort of
a vague abstract concern people didn't
care but now a lot of people who are
entering into college now have relatives
or you know older siblings of friends or
somebody they know who's basically
living in their parents basement not
able to get a decent job but with 150
thousand dollars in student loan debt so
it's really changed the way they think
about it so did you say there's maybe an
epidemic of but these colleges are
facing that there is going to be a lower
entrance rate of students actually
wanting to get in yes and you're
actually seeing them you're seeing
declining enrollments in some schools
you're seeing much much more price
resistance on the part of both parents
and students and right now the way
schools typically deal with that is not
by overtly discounting although a few
places have really cut their tuition but
mostly it's its covert discounting which
they call financial aid but what
financial aid really is is price
discrimination it's a mechanism whereby
they can set the price at the highest
price you can possibly pay and they've
begun to sort of offer more incentives
to come to schools as a way of dealing
with people's resistance to paying full
Bo or even close to it we talked about
this bubble and you know the eventual
burst is coming what is that going to
look like well it's already happening in
my world which is legal education and
what it looks like it's kind of ugly I
mean you have law schools that are
laying off faculty or encouraging you to
take early retirement or buyouts you
have places whose survival over the next
few years is really in doubt because
their tuition driven and students aren't
showing up to pay their high tuitions I
think you know law school is being hit
harder because there also some
structural changes in the legal market
and also it's seen as more optional
people still kind of think that you're
not a respectable member of the middle
class if you don't have a college degree
and they don't think that about a lot of
you so it's hitting us first but I think
it's it's inevitable that it's going to
hit colleges in much the same way and
again you're already seeing the early
signs of that even their college degree
now is a glorified high school degree
why then do you think that businesses
still require that even entry-level jobs
that you have to have a four-year degree
well there are a couple of reasons I
mean one is a four-year degree says
something it says that first of all it
says you come from associate
a group that can go to college which
actually is probably the thing that
businesses look for the most it also
says that you can work with other people
and not get kicked out for getting in
fights or other unacceptable behavior
you have at least a certain amount of
ability to sort of show up when you're
supposed to and do what you're supposed
to all which are fairly useful but it's
a very expensive signifier now the
businesses don't care it's not expensive
for them at least not directly but again
it's it's a six-figure investment four
or more years of your life I mean
actually a lot of students take six
years to graduate now and if all it gets
you is sort of you know your ticket
punch like a high school diploma diploma
used to be that's an awfully expensive
credential we talked a little bit about
focusing on vocational type training you
have the massive open online courses
beyond that do you see anything else
that's kind of emerging as an
alternative one of the things we're
starting to see is certification which
so goes with the vocational training to
some degree where third parties certify
that you possess certain skills and
you've seven software for a while with
Microsoft certification and things like
that
but you're getting seen in more and more
areas and both one way you know this is
a trend is that the folks at ETS and a
CT have gotten on board and they are now
putting up their own certification tests
which basically right now people are
supposed to take when they graduate
college to prove they actually learned
something in college which tells you
something already and there's another
test called the CLA Plus which comes
from another group that is much more
explicitly focused on workplace skills
as well so I think you know the logical
trend for those is for people to say
wait if we can take the test why do the
college before it if the test says we're
competent and we can rely on the test
why not learn what we need to learn
however way works best for us and it's
cheapest and then take the test and move
on I mean we've seen this the explosion
of online learning and these
certification courses but do you think
that the business community are they
warming up to it at all are they still a
little bit weary of all that it depends
on the sector in the manufacturing
industry there they're actually really
pushing these certificates because they
find that people come out of the
educational machinery not knowing how to
do the stuff they need anyway in other
areas I think
see and of course there'll be some some
areas like your high-end publishing and
stuff like that where they're gonna want
you to have a Yale degree just because
but you know those are a relatively
small part of the marketplace and it's
kind of a weird thing that's happened
with American Society this idea that you
have to have a college degree to be a
respectable member of the middle class
because as recently 30 or 40 years ago
that wasn't really true and it's not
that college has gotten so much better
over the last 30 or 40 years you know
the research says people earn less in
college than they used to so it's it's
sort of odd that it's it's become a
status symbol but santa symbols are
fundamentally kind of unamerican in that
regard and the idea that you should have
to put in four plus years doing
something you don't really want to do
just to be taken seriously as a member
of society it seems kind of odd do you
think that without the recession that we
would be talking about this or that
there would be as much focus on this
higher education bubble that there is
now yeah I mean I think would have taken
longer you know they have a saying in
the business community that when the
tide goes out you can see who's not
wearing pants and that's what happens
with recessions and that's happened with
higher education if the economy were
booming the same trends would be
underway because the underlying trend is
that the tuition costs have increased
more than double the rate of income and
as long as that happens you've got a gap
that can't be filled forever if the
economy were booming it wouldn't be as
obvious as fast but you can't something
can't go on forever it won't as I say in
the book and what can't go on forever is
tuition costs growing faster than family
incomes and that's been going on now for
twenty thirty years yeah and it's
interesting because families as we
talked about the status and we'll still
see it as worth leveraging you know
major debt to send their kids into
school and you know you just had a
daughter go off to college did you put
any stipulations on her funding you know
was there a particular major that she
had to do no but she's going somewhere
cheap and I think you know she's in an
artist program at a inexpensive state
school that it's a good program but we
certainly looked at return on investment
and so did she I mean she and the kids
her age are much more conscious of
student loan debt I think than people
were even five years ago you can really
see it and she went to this gifted
program that Duke runs a some
and all of them are very focused on
return on investment for college because
they realized that it's it's a big deal
what about kids that want just maybe the
college experience do you see like on
their cottage industries you know for
budding entrepreneurs out there that
want to create just well yeah hangout
for people right the college I mean one
thing I suggest in the book is that you
know if people want to go to college
online but they still want the college
experience you know of dorm living and
late-night pizzas and partying and stuff
I don't know why anyway well you know
but that somebody should just set up a
campus outsource all the teaching bring
you know have all the courses online
from other places hire some unemployed
PhDs of whom there were plenty to act as
on-site tutors and provide just that
part just the dorms and the pizza and
stuff like that and there is a business
model it's not quite the same as that
but High Point University in North
Carolina is all about the amenities and
Andy Rosen wrote a book about education
a few years ago where he put it up as a
cautionary tale of how colleges have
become driven by amenities there they
have single dorm rooms with double beds
and kitchens and granite countertops and
their own bathroom everything they have
ice cream trucks that roam around campus
giving out free ice cream and he said
the problem is this is a cautionary tale
I already read the book said I want to
go there so why not just take it to the
next level the state of college right
now you could trace a lot back the
problems back through K through 12
education and just what a dismal state
that's in do you think that the solution
for that is just as simple as allowing
more choice oh absolutely and you know
it is it's actually odd how our current
system of public education has there
should you so many rigidities in the
people's lives because where people live
you know how long the commute is all
kinds of things how much their house is
worth are all driven by basically public
school districts and you may choose an
area for the good schools for your kids
then the school board waives its magic
wand and your redistricting and now your
kids are in bad schools but you're still
stuck with a long commute and by the way
your property values have dropped twenty
thousand dollars because of the wave of
that magic wand so it's not it's not
optimal and there's no particular reason
why somebody should have to commute an
hour each way just so their kid can have
a decent school that's just how it's
set up for so long there are so many
alternatives now that weren't around a
few years ago and it's not only stuff I
mean you know 20 30 years ago most
communities had a public school system
then there's a private school that was
probably religious usually Catholic and
then maybe there was a Tony or pseudo
Tony private prep school and those were
your choices now there's an online
school there's homeschooling there were
charter schools there's just a wide
variety of other options and it's not
only that the public schools are getting
worse and pushing people out but it's
also that these alternatives that have
sprung up really pulling people in as
well because it's just better talking
about school choice do you see that
option becoming more politically viable
I think sometimes people think it's you
know right-wing Republican thing but
then you have people like Sonia
Sotomayor who is a product of that do
you see a way forward school choice is
super popular in the inner city and that
makes sense when you look at the schools
in the inner city and I think you know
there are a few Republicans who are
beginning to see it as a wedge issue in
the inner city and maybe it is but the
bottom line is school choice is
something everybody wants really and
there are as I say many more things to
choose from I think a lot of big city
schools are basically imploding right
now because parents are banding them
they're literally closing schools and
laying off teachers because they've lost
so many people and that's really
extraordinary when you think about it
because from the standpoint of an
individual parent at least public school
is basically free and people are willing
to surrender a free good and spend their
own money and if their homeschooling
also a lot of their own time educating
their kids somewhere else just because
the free product is so lousy and I think
that the options that people have now
make it much easier to do that and the
thing that will save the public schools
if they're smart enough which remains
open to question is charter schools and
other things that let people try new
stuff but still under the umbrella of
the public school system instead of
exiting completely when I was reading
this book and you know talking about
technology saving education it sounds
great but then you see stories like here
in California where they spent a billion
dollars on iPads it seems like the
schools can't use the technology to save
themselves or even if they try it in the
book I explicitly did
claim that I'm recommending what I call
dumb solutions like give every kid an
iPad there's nothing magic about the
technology you know a kid in a lousy
school with an iPad is just a kid in a
lousy school who now has an iPad what
the technology lets you do though is it
lets you try other approaches so for
example you know the Khan Academy is
famous for its flipped classroom model
where you know in the traditional
classroom the teacher stands up front
and lectures the kids take problems home
and try to work them on their own which
is not so great because their parents
usually don't know the answers under the
car model they flip it the kids watch
the lectures on videos at home then they
come into the classroom and they work
the problems when the teachers right
there to help and explain things well
it's really not the technology that's
doing the work there it's just making
that possible yeah we see people
becoming empowered under this movement
and in 2006 you wrote your book an army
of David's and you were very optimistic
about how you know future and technology
would really empower people to make
changes are you still feeling an
optimistic about that oh yeah pretty
much I mean I have to say you know it's
hard to believe it's been long since I
wrote that book but most of that has
been born out and you certainly see it
in the education area where there is
just a whole lot of ferment I mean
there's more change and excitement going
on in both k12 and higher education now
than there has been for a hundred years
and a lot of stuff that people try is
not going to work but what's left will
be something that's new and better yeah
and you know you started it's dependent
you know right after 9/11 you hear the
blog father like to call you and do you
still think the blogosphere is kind of
this force for cultural change or do you
think that it's too becoming co-opted
and kind of losing its edge of it well
it depends I mean you know the it's
blogging I wrote when blogging was new
and exciting and now it's it's old
school it's so old school that like in
the in the condo we're renting when we
hear that way there's a copy of German
glamour and it has a German article on
lifestyle bloggers and and some of them
are called traditional lifestyle
bloggers and I was laughing because
everything about both the Germans think
it's traditional you know it must be old
but if they're still there I mean the
truth is there were more people reading
blogs now and writing them than there
were when people thought they were
exciting and new 1012 years ago and of
course it's
and other stuff I mean blogs were just
one of the earliest forms of social
media but you have Twitter you have
Facebook you have everything that's
growing up and there'll be new stuff
next year that we're not even talking
about now the important thing is that
it's people talking directly to other
people without gatekeepers and I think
that that's a good trend and I don't see
it going away though I think a lot of
powers-that-be wish it would recently
over the last few years or so you've
become a little bit more outspoken
politically and you know we're heading
into these midterms we've got you know
everyone's already talking about 2016 do
you really think it matters who's in
power or do we kind of see now that
everything's kind of the same and it's
kind of just this Kabuki theater going
on I think it matters who's in power I
think that it's true that depending on
which parties in power you get different
flavors of lousy nasai have flavors I
like that no there's in flavors I don't
like as much so I think I think it does
matter I think that longer term the
question is going to be really how long
the two party is going to be able to run
the Kabuki theater and do their best to
avoid what people really want because
the truth is the public has a set of
priorities which and all you have to
even look at the polls from Gallup or
pew to see the public parties and what
Washington considers priorities are very
different and well I like to say
something that can't go on forever I
don't think that can go on forever
either so I think there'll be some kind
of a realignment that's going to bring
those things closer together
speaking of realignment because we see
more people declaring as independence
what do you make about that neither the
parties that really cover themselves
with glory and neither one is even in a
position to run very effectively on me
well we may not be great but we're
better than the other guys theory
anymore because that that sort of been
running to the ground as well it's hard
for me to know when people call
themselves independents sometimes that
just means I don't want to take
responsibility for my views or I'm
afraid you'll think less of me if I tell
you what I really think but I do think
that you know the traditional parties
used to be a coalition of interest that
really sort of got something out of
being in a coalition together and now
I'm not convinced that their breakup
value
isn't more than their value is going
concerns so many people look to you as a
hero you're a huge figure on the
internet who is your hair who's Glenn
Reynolds Tara's they're an entreprenuer
an innovator or someone the legal field
that you really look up to oh that's
interesting
um my favorite writer in the entire
world as I've said in my blog is Arthur
Allen laughs who was a law professor at
Yale who died right before I got there
but he was very big on touching people's
balloons and my favorite thing that he
wrote was a piece in the Stanford Law
Review called memorandum for from the
devil and it was because Roberto Unger
who was a professor at Harvard had
written a rather pretentious book called
knowledge and politics and the last line
in the book is speak God and so left
responded in the form of a memorandum
from the devil saying that when
non-ironic divine address comes from
Lionel Hall even such as I must take
notice and it was just a brutal takedown
of the moral pretensions of academia so
I guess that's my big hero and I
encourage people look at memorandum from
the devil by Arthur Allen laughs it's
it's short and some of the best writing
you'll read anywhere well go ahead and
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you infer reason TV I'm Alexis
Garcia
you